tired of your old iPhone 5s feel like  something new you're in luck this is the  iPhone 6 which has a 4.7 inch display  that's a bit larger than the iPhone 5s  is 4 inch display and to accommodate  that display Apple had to make some  changes to the hardware they've moved  the sleep/wake button to the side of the  phone which used to be on the top and  they've also incorporated some clever  features like double tapping on the home  button which brings the content of the  screen down so you can reach all the way  across with your thumb this new display  has more than 1 million pixels and it is  a retina HD display which is 38% more  pixels than what was in the iPhone 5s it  is also thinner at 6 point 9 millimeters  that is pretty slender compared compared  to the iPhone 5s is 7 point 6 millimeter  thickness from before the phone will go  on sale for pre-orders September 12  delivery September 19th prices start at  $199 for 16 gigs $2.99 for 64 gigs and  399 for 128 gigs